Après avoir traversé la planète pour visiter les Etats-Unis d'Amérique,
puis découvrir la culture japonaise de l'autre côté du globe,
Cyprien a décidé d'assouvir sa soif de culture étrangère en allant
en Espagne !
Alors, faut savoir que moi, à la base, j'suis pas trop prédestiné à visiter l'Espagne
J'ai fait 9 années d'allemand LV1
autant dire que ça m'a servi absolument à rien là-bas
J'ai un petit peu préparé mon séjour en Espagne, hein
J'ai même appris un petit peu d'espagnol pendant plusieurs semaines
Et bien sûr, j'ai commencé par Barcelone, et bien sûr, à Barcelone, on parle catalan.
Pffff... j'm'étais tellement préparé ! J'étais deg !
Et bien sûr, les Barcelonais se font un malin plaisir à te corriger tout le temps
D'ailleurs, faut savoir qu'à Barcelone, la majorité des touristes sont français
Je sais de quoi je parle, hein, moi-même je viens de France.
Et y'a un truc incroyable que j'ai pu entendre de la bouche de plusieurs français là-bas
"Et si on allait au parc Guell après ?
Encore des Français...
Ils sont partout...
Et toi, tu es quoi ? Tu viens d'une autre planète, peut-être ?
T'es un extraterreste, c'est ça ?
Bah oui.
Ah..."
C'est simple, y'a tellement de français à Barcelone que je suis tombé sur des serveurs français.
"Un sandwich de pernil !
Si. Un sandwich au jambon.
De pernil !
Oui oui ! Au jambon..
*Je voudrais un sandwich au jambon !!*
Ca, c'est de l'allemand !
Et bah voilà, j'ai perdu mon catalan !"
J'suis tellement nul en espagnol que...
J'me suis taper la honte de ma vie là-bas...
On était en voiture avec des potes...
"C'est bizarre, y'a pas Salida dans le routard...
Pourtant, c'est indiqué partout...
Peut-être qu'il n'y a rien à voir dans cette ville...
Salida, ça veut dire "sortie", en espagnol...
Ah ouais, ouais, je savais... je savais, bien sûr..."
Une des différences avec la France, c'est notamment les horaires des magasins,
puisque tous les petits commerces ferment entre 13h et 16h...
Et là, j'me suis dit
POURQUOI ?
Et puis je me suis promené l'été en Andalousie à 14h
Et là, tous s'est expliqué...
Il faisait tellement chaud que quand je sortais,
je me collais contre les murs pour bénéficier de quinze centimètres d'ombre...
"Bon bah on y va, hein !
C'est joli, l'Andalousie à 14h, hein ?
Oh, regardez, là-bas... Ah merde !!
Un coup de soleil !
Après, j'vais pas me plaindre du beau temps, ça c'est sûr
D'ailleurs, y'a un truc que je peux pas m'empêcher de faire
dès que je bouge à l'étranger ou dans le Sud de la France,
c'est que je regarde la météo à Paris, et plus il fait moche là-bas,
plus je kiffe !
L'homme le plus fourbe de France !
Et, à l'inverse, ce qui m'énerve grave
"Salut Cyprien, alors c'est bien l'Espagne ? Ici, à Paris, il fait...
super beau...
NOOOON !!!
Un des trucs que j'ai préféré en Espagne, c'est la nourriture
Et un truc qui m'a étonné, c'est qu'en fait, ils font des boîtes de conserve de qualité
Genre c'est reconnu, et tout
Et y'a même des bars à tapas, qui te servent des tapas qui sortent de conserves
C'est comme ça ! Faut s'y faire !
"J'vais vous prendre des "patatas bravas" et des artichauts
Si !
D'accord, en fait, c'est ça ?
Woaah ! Vous êtes cuisinier, vous aussi ?
Si !
Vous avez fait Top Chef, non ?
C'est vous, Thierry Marx ?
Si !
C'est vous, Ghislaine Arabian ? Vous êtes Ghislaine Arabian, c'est ça ?
Bref, l'Espagne, c'est mortel !
J'ai adoré la nature
MANGER !
la culture
les espagnols
MANGEEER
Et, comme on dit en Espagne, Auf Wiedersehen !
Ca, c'est de l'allemand !
MERDE !!